[Music]
like welcome to scrambles and this one's
done with a bit of a bit of a difference
it's a scrambled with spice
I hope look at that in this incredible
area also right we were standing there
with beautiful coffee plantation is
growing some of the most amazing spices
I've ever seen in my entire life so why
not use those local spices and create
something a little bit more magical now
there'll be a traditional scrambled egg
we're done with a little bit of a black
masala there were two chili powder with
turmeric first off start sweating off
the onions okay
so again keep this quite rustic okay get
it on little touch 4g okay just a touch
beautiful now stop find those onions
really nicely caramelized
of Chile
no types of tumor
relax oh and just a touch
such a fat farm
now get those onions
the spices from her
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
now get them you free caramelizing like
that next and we'll put a little bit of
green chili in there okay I want this to
be too hot gonna keep the seeds in right
if I fry that off it's gonna get it
really nice template
[Music]
beautiful and then from there we
streamline up a little bit with some
tortoise that's gonna help almost like a
little bit of a sort of cooling agent
and swing things up but but do you think
of Cara the region we're in it's about
the land of spice
English boy
well my
I'm just tell the gas please be done
beautiful heat
get that Karen boys now don't care about
those onions tomatoes chilies and spices
he'll be too hot and also too watery
okay from there get your eggs
in
[Music]
give it a little mix no salt and then
don't touch too many ways
okay don't touch my cheek oh I know
toxified I saw it just a touch make some
nicely now it's premiums and we put down
nice at the very end literally use these
sort of almost like a cooling agent the
topless 4x at the end and then looks
like that
don't touch of coriander mix that it's
beautiful
all the coriander onions everything's
from let's trade the back garden
yeah
put that down you really important there
we worry about nicely caramelized all
that water's got to go out get
everything beautifully cooked and then I
saw the eggs if I get that sort of
undercut that's getting watery if I turn
the eggs would be watery and you won't
get that really sort of have nice spice
you want this toast those spices off
otherwise it's too raw and rotate the
eggs would be too powerful
and useful
[Music]
[Music]
get in there
[Music]
beautiful
starts to come together create the
seasoning touch of salt in just a touch
and now the coconut milk okay it's gonna
be literary right the end they'll cool
it down cook that cooking now and now
let's slow down the cooking process take
that out chop them up and here
traditionally scrambled eggs are sort of
almost like sort of overcooked so take
it a little step further and then
folding it touch the coconut milk at the
end on there so it's easy just salt
before bin spring onions I coriander and
then just lightly roll that in beautiful
I just come to serve it with a beautiful
bread wonderful roasted bread sit that
in the middle and then from there thanks
usually done and talked spicy rich and
then you know to cool that down I've got
some beautiful preserved pickled onions
just literally sit there and Tom and
there is a beautiful southern Indian
style spicy scrambled eggs done look at
it hot spicy and delicious let me know
in the comments what you think of that
amazing scrambled egg dish and if you
missed uncharted trust me you can watch
it on the link below or on the NatGeo
app
[Music]